Ever since "Game of Thrones" became a major
hit for HBO, networks have been searching
for the next big epic fantasy series to mimic
that kind of success.
Netflix found its own success with "The Witcher,"
a show that broke viewership records at the
time of its first season's release.
Amazon, on the other hand, has doubled down
on its hopes for fantasy-laden success with
both a series based on "The Wheel of Time"
books and a show tackling the Second Age of
Tolkien's Middle-earth.
It's an ambitious and expensive move for the
company, but one that shows Amazon's dedication
to the fantasy genre and its fans.
"Whatever happens now, there's no turning
back."
"The Wheel of Time" is based on the book series
of the same name by authors Robert Jordan
and Brandon Sanderson, which spans 14 main
novels and a handful of other works set in
the universe, including — perhaps most relevantly
— a prequel novella entitled "New Spring."
Jordan died in 2007, two years after the 11th
book had been released, which left the future
of the series in doubt at the time.
However, epic fantasy up-and-comer Sanderson
took over and, with detailed notes from Jordan
and oversight by Jordan's wife and longtime
editor, completed the final three books and
brought the series to a satisfying close.
Since then, fans have been left wondering
how long it would take for an adaptation to
come to fruition.
Well, thanks to Amazon, that wait is over.
Here's what we know so far about the upcoming
first season of "The Wheel of Time" show.
According to the official synopsis,
"The story follows Moiraine, a member of the
shadowy and influential all-female organization
called the 'Aes Sedai' as she embarks on a
dangerous, world-spanning journey with five
young men and women.
Moiraine believes one of them might be the
reincarnation of an incredibly powerful individual,
whom prophecies say will either save humanity
or destroy it."
This description falls more or less in line
with the plot of the first book, "The Eye
of the World," though judging by the first
trailer, we're going to be seeing quite a
bit of action that happens off-page in the
books, and even meeting a few characters that
don't factor in until later.
Unlike the binge model that Netflix uses,
Amazon is continuing its trend of weekly episode
releases.
However, binge watchers need not fret entirely,
as the first three episodes of "The Wheel
of Time" will drop all at once on Amazon Prime
Video on November 19.
From that point forward, episodes will be
released weekly all the way through December
24.
There will be eight episodes of Season 1 in
total.
While those who enjoy binge watching may be
disappointed by the news that "The Wheel of
Time" will release episodes on a weekly basis
as opposed to all at once, this is certainly
a strategy that's worked well in the past.
One could argue that talking and theorizing
was half the fun of watching shows like "Game
of Thrones" and "Lost" in real time with everybody
else.
The production of Season 1 was hampered by
COVID-related delays, but the wait shouldn't
be so long for Season 2.
Amazon's betting big on the show's performance,
and has already greenlit the sophomore set.
Production commenced last summer.
Given that "The Wheel of Time" books are high
fantasy, they contain quite a large assortment
of characters.
It's even become a joke among the fandom that
keeping track of named characters is a challenging
task.
Amazon's adaptation will have to make some
adjustments in this regard, but many of the
core cast members are already in place, with
one very notable exception.
Arguably the biggest cast member will be Rosamund
Pike.
She will portray Moiraine Damodred, an Aes
Sedai of the Blue Ajah.
The Aes Sedai are a faction of women who wield
the One Power, this universe's version of
magic.
Josha Stradowski will play Rand al'Thor, who
serves as the major protagonist of the book
series.
Marcus Rutherford and Barney Harris will step
into the roles of Perrin Aybara and Mat Cauthon,
respectively.
It's important to note that the role of Cauthon
has been recast for Season 2, so don't fall
too deeply in love with Harris' portrayal
in Season 1.
Some of the other cast members for "The Wheel
of Time" Season 1 include Zoë Robins as Nynaeve
al'Meara, Madeleine Madden as Egwene al'Vere,
the girl covered in paint in the trailer;
and Daniel Henney as Lan Mandragoran, Moiraine's
Warder and the heir to a lost throne.
The one glaring omission?
Where in Randland is Elayne?
The casting of the Daughter-Heir of Andor
has yet to be revealed, as of the making of
this video, despite her playing a crucial
role in "The Eye of the World."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.